there's no way a fidgety and skeptical
news anchor would ever have started
meditating were it not for the science
the science is really compelling it
shows that meditation can boost your
immune system lower your blood pressure
help you deal with problems ranging from
irritable bowel syndrome to psoriasis
and the neuroscience is where it really
gets sci-fi there was a study out of
Harvard that shows that short daily
doses of meditation can literally grow
the gray matter in key areas of your
brain having to do with self-awareness
and compassion and shrink the gray
matter in the area associated with
stress there was also a study out of
Yale that looked at what's called the
default mode Network of the brain it's a
connected series of brain regions that
are active during most of our waking
hours when we're doing that thing that
human beings do all the time which is
obsessing about ourselves thinking about
the past thinking about the future doing
anything but being focused on what's
happening right now meditators not only
turn off the default mode Network of
their brain while they're meditating but
even when they're not meditating in
other words meditators are setting a new
default mode and what's that default
mode they're focused on what's happening
right now in sports this is called being
in the zone
it's nothing mystical it's not magical
you're not floating off into cosmic ooze
you are just being where you are the
cliche and self-help circles as being in
the now you can use that term if you
want but it because it's accurate it's
slightly annoying but it's accurate it's
it's more just being focused on what
you're doing and the the benefits of
that are enormous and this is why you're
seeing these unlikely meditators now
while you're seeing the US Marines
adopting at the US Army corporate
executives from the head of for to the
founders of Twitter athletes from Phil
Jackson to many many Olympians
scientists doctors lawyers
schoolchildren there's this sort of
elite subculture of high achievers who
are adopting this because they know it
can help you be more focused on what
you're doing and it can stop you from
being yanked around by the voice in your
head my powers of prognostication are
not great I bought a
stock in the company that made Palm
Pilot back in 2000 that didn't go so
well for me but having said that I'm
going to make a prediction I think we're
looking at meditation as the next big
public health revolution in the 1940s if
you tell people that you went running
they would say who's chasing you right
now if you tell people you meditate and
I have a lot of experience with telling
people this they're going to look at you
like you're a little weird most of the
time that's going to change meditation
is going to join the pantheon of
no-brainers like exercise brushing your
teeth and taking the meds that your
doctor prescribes - these are all things
that if you don't do you feel guilty
about and that is where I think we're
heading with meditation because the
science is so strongly suggestive that
meditation can do really really great
things for your brain and for your body
the common assumption that we have it
may be subconscious is that our
happiness really depends on external
factors how is our childhood have we won
the lottery recently did we marry well
did we marry at all but in fact
meditation suggests that happiness is
actually a skill something you can train
just the way you can train your body in
the gym it's a self-generated thing and
that's a really radical notion it
doesn't mean that external circumstances
aren't going to impact your happiness it
doesn't mean you're not going to be
subject to the vagaries of an
impermanent entropic universe
it just means you were going to be able
to navigate this with a little bit more
ease